all right so you know what no you check
this is your moment I was about you can
explain to me what just happened and the
Golden Globe goes to brie Larson all I
remember is I needed to go to the
bathroom I went to the bathroom and as I
was leaving Helen Mirren was like don't
go right now your category is coming up
and I was like no it's not
I felt like an hour more to go and then
Kate once I was like don't go right now
I was like I have to like I still have
an hour and I wasn't looking at the
clock which was a big problem so there
was a long line at the bathroom and I
just waited did my thing second I got
back to my chair the category came up I
was like I was about good or better I
can call you by surprise but good good
you didn't have to think about it very
much bad because I was like mid about to
reapply chapstick and I'm like oh
so basically when you're when you're
category came up you are like halfway
through your chapstick and now it's time
for Best Actress in it and I was like
comedy drama No